well
hello how are you greetings sal y jaramillo
with the most outstanding headlines of the
day another round of rental and
mortgage assistance is on its way to the
las vegas valley clark county is about to
receive $93 million in relief
for the housing division  From
Nevada, the state has already received 124
million dollars through the
Pérez Housing Existing Assistance Program, which has
already helped 29,000 people in the Valley
pay their rents and mortgages, and these
new funds hope to help another
20,000 families in Las Vegas
today.  one of the largest hotel companies in
the valley will reveal its
financial outlook
verveer you are the parent company of station
casinos will publish its earnings for the
last quarter of the year and analysts
anticipate that the company will reveal
notable losses in sales and a
decline of more than 25 percent  to its
profits due to restrictions and
closures due to the pandemic, the company
has a very different fiscal outlook
Compared to the hotels and casinos
in the hotel zone, this company does not
depend on conventions or
foreign tourism to support its four
properties, since most of its
clientele is local and domestic, and
sad news in the world of
entertainment for the member  original of the
group the supremes has died at the
age of 76
woods died monday at his home here in
las vegas the cause of his death is still
unknown the group of his crime is
known as the most successful
motown girl group
now we move on to his prognosis  of the
weather, a partially cloudy day is expected,
the maximum will be at 65
degrees and the minimum at 49. Have a
good day. I am salt and medium rockrose and this
was Kirchner in Spanish
[Music]